all right first of all gonna start this
out with a big thank you to you all for
enjoying my top 10 best movies of 2015
let's let's be honest this is the list
you really want to see you love the top
10 worst lists yes say this I get it
that everyone loves a good bloodbath I
will say making a top 10 list of any
kind best or worst it's a very hard
thing to do me not all the movies that
deserve to be on the list make the list
there are only 10 slots making this
particular list of the top 10 worst
movies of 2015 was the hardest top 10
worst list I have ever made my life
there were at one point 24 candidates to
be in the top 10 worst list some of them
weren't going to make it so when I
whittled it down and still had 15 15
movies at all definitely deserve to be
on this list
but only 10 made it and as I said my top
10 best movies of 2015 video I did not
see every movie that came out in 2015
but whereas in that video I said it in
an apologetic tone here I apologize for
none of it sometimes you just got to
skip out on some garbage but trust me I
saw enough [ __ ] in 2015 to make this
video with proper confidence so let's
just get right into this list and talk
about the top 10 worst movies of 2015
for me otherwise known as the top 10
movies I hated more than pixels number
10 that one awkward ass comedy called
vacation does sequel ish soft reboot
movies sometimes they work sometimes
they don't this is one of the ones but
it just didn't work and a lot of people
I knew were like that movie's gonna suck
balls and I wasn't other ones like we'll
see I should have just listened to
everybody Ed Helms plays the same
character he plays in everything plays
Andy Bernard from the office again
Christina Applegate at least offered
something to this movie she's the reason
this movie isn't higher on the list
number 9 number 9 is unfinished business
yeah you remember that one comedy with
Vince Vaughn Dave Franco and Tom Wilkins
yeah I get it
you don't remember neither does anyone
else this movie was a comedy that was
just boring as [ __ ] this is one of the
more forgettable comedies of 2015 I will
say that at least there is that at least
it's like well if you forget the pain
that the pain really happened the most
important thing a comedy is supposed to
do is make you laugh this movie just
bored me not good number eight number
eight another awkward ask this really
funny I just realized the bottom three
movies on my top 10 worst
our common hold on after this there are
no more comedy movies that are kind of
funny didn't mean to be though yeah Hot
Pursuit oh my god
Reese Witherspoon Sofia Vergara had no
chemistry in this movie whatsoever at a
point in this [ __ ] mess I looked at
the person who left me
I knew the person so it wasn't weird and
I was like there is nothing this movie
can do at this point
there's just nothing yeah this movie's
like a car crash in slow motion you're
like I could look away oh it's so sad
number seven number seven on this list
okay you remember when I said my top 10
favorite movies of 2015 that James Bond
got a facelift for a younger generation
that was Kingsman the Secret Service
yeah and now fatal attractions gotten a
facelift for a younger generation and it
was just god-awful with the boy next
door the one thing about this movie is
Jennifer Lopez is attractive but it's
just not enough to make a good movie the
acting was [ __ ] the premise was executed
like [ __ ] I mean a fatal attraction kind
of scenario that that's entertaining
could be anyway not this time you
deserve better than this I deserve
better than this we all deserve better
than this movie number six number six
sex and a murder mystery should be
interesting this movie made it [ __ ]
boring that's the loft and it's really
funny about this I compared this movie
to clue I also compared the hateful
eight to clue nothing like the hateful
eight the shitty execution in this
boring-ass movie with the overacting the
under acting all culminated for me to be
like I don't know if this year holds
because it came out pretty early in the
air but there is a very good chance it's
gonna be in my top ten worst list and it
was number five number five is pad holy
God how do you make Peter Pan boring
this is how funny I was in Disneyland
when I saw I was in the most magical
place on earth watching a movie that
springboards off of the most magical
place on earth and none of it was
magical from the moment the pirate
starts singing Nirvana in the beginning
I was like so this is off like the
writer this movie saw a night stale when
they were singing we will rock and he
was a common to do that but I'm gonna do
it in a Peter Pan moving it's gonna kill
oh no it just didn't work at all this
movie was boring it was brown for half
the movie in Neverland and then it
starts getting color but it's kind of
like a lifeless pale dead
body that you paint makeup on it's still
a lifeless pale ass dead body it just
now has colors that's what it feels like
when you start seeing some of the
vibrant colors of Neverland in this
movie the movie murdered Disney magic I
can't say enough bad things about that
war number four is ironically Fantastic
Four I feel like this is gonna be higher
up on a lot of other top ten worst list
for 2015
rightfully so go for it kill it people
just so happens there are three other
movies this year I hate him more than
this one this movie was bad when I first
saw it it just got worse when I thought
about it oh my god the frente this
should be a fun movie at least this
movie take any of the fun that could
have been in its apt it all out for this
dark ass brooding ass boring ass movie
this movie is the epitome of what
happens when a studio and a director
have a shitty-ass relationship we all
suffer and it's painful it really makes
you scratch your head as to why Fox is
holding on to this property so they
don't make money on the property because
no one saw this movie so sell it to
Marvel Studios so we can have the
Fantastic Four in some Marvel Cinematic
Universe movies makes sense they can
grind out a little profit when they sell
it to them as it stands we will not get
another Fantastic Four anything for a
very long time because of this movie
number three funny thing as this list
started out with three comedies it ends
with three horror movies unintentional I
promise but as for number three we have
sinister - alright sinister one when I
saw it was one of the more interesting
horror movies I had seen in a while at
the time I saw it saw it's kind of
looking forward to sinister - but not
really putting all my chips in that
basket because I know how sequel itis
works turns out to class the case of
sequel itis first movie made money so
you got to pump out a shitty script for
a sequel no matter what have the iconic
elements from the first movie in the
second movie even if they don't make
sense funny things this movie wasn't
even sinister it wasn't even really
about the ghostly [ __ ] in the boogeyman
but is about this lady trying to escape
her ex oh yeah and the kid in the
basement watch his snuff films because a
little ghost kids make him top that off
and sprinkle it with some shitty child
acting you have number three on my top
10 shittiest movies of 2015
no but - we're down to number two we are
in the [ __ ] folks and the movies in this
franchise have just gotten worse
Paranormal Activity the ghost dimension
Paranormal Activity started out as a
pretty neat thing I thought little
boring but still an interesting thing
because at least
tenshun you didn't see the ghost so
there was mystery involved what to do
now her well let's put a camera in the
movie that just shows the ghost to take
away any mystery that this movie might
have so this movie is as bad as the
worst Paranormal Activity movie that you
can think of with none of the mystery
that that movie that was bad had at all
oh my god what a Sun news the ghost
didn't even look neat it was just a blob
that's all it was was a lifeless
formless massless venom assuming it
looking blob
where'd is the ghost dimension is the
last Paranormal Activity movie I'm
crossing my fingers for that [ __ ] all
these movies are doing at this point is
taking up one slot and my top 10 worst
movies of the year list no whoa whoa oh
my god we're here
number one the shittiest movie of 2015
the biggest horror movie that 2015
offered to us it gave it to us early on
in the year and that is of course Fifty
Shades of [ __ ] oh my god talk about
sex being boring in the lock at least it
tried to be a mystery this is everything
shitty about Twilight just repackaged
and done again here's some perspective
why light was horrible Fifty Shades of
Grey the book started out as Twilight
fan fiction that's right Fifty Shades of
Grey started out as a shittier version
of Twilight the author wrote it on her
blackberry and it shows the characters
were shitty they were born you were
literally sitting there with a gun to
your head
I had to Drudge through some like I have
to do a video on this this is work this
was one of those scenarios where my
youtube channel becomes work once in a
while it happens this was the time but
it's okay because we have some really
interesting S&M [ __ ] right at least
that's gonna be exciting uh-uh no I
can't illustrate how boring this movie
actually was and that is why it's number
one it is the shittiest movie at 2015
thus saith me in my list why folks so
that is it now you have seen my top 10
best movies of 2015 my top 10 worst
movies of 2015 it was an interesting
year we had some good ones and funny
enough when I was making the list like
there have been a lot of shitty movies
this year hopefully 2016 picks it up I
really hope it looks like it can be a
good year so once again for you what are
the top 10 shittiest movies of 2015 I
really want to hear this one because I
get a kick out of it just like you do so
whatever
comment below let me know again thank
you for another great exciting and fun
year on YouTube I'm looking forward to
2016 with you all and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more